مشروع ولو الذي يتوقع مشاهدينا موافقه
الاداره الامريكيه عليه يقع شمال غرب
ولايه الاسكا الامريكيه تكلفه هذا المشروع
ستصل عند اكتماله الى نحو ثمانيه مليار
دولار امريكي بقياده شركه النفط العملاقه
كونوكو فيليبس القدره الانتاجيه من
المفترض ان تزيد بحسب تقديرات عن 600
مليون برميل من النفط الخام على مدار 30
عاما كما نتابع في هذه الصوره خلفيه وهذا
الرقم هو اساس يومي يعني انتاج 180 الف
برميل من النفط مؤيد المشروع يرون انه
يوجد واقتصاديه كبيره لسكان المنطقه
بتوفير
2500 فرصه عمل كما انه سيضيف للخزينه
الامريكيه ما يصل الى 17 مليار دولار من
العائدات سيضيفها الحكومه على الجانب
الاخر يتحدث المنتقدون عن ان التنقيب
سيؤدي الى اطلاق ما يقرب من 280 مليون طن
من انبعاثات الكربون في الغلاف الجوي
سنويا وهو ما يعادل اضافه مليون سياره الى
الطرق الامريكيه كل عاما اذا مشاهدينا
نبقى مع منتقديه مشروع ويلو والجماعات
المدافعه عن البيئه مجموعه العمل البيئي
بدات اجراءات رفع دعوه ضد الاداره
الامريكيه بحجه ان سلطه بايدن لحمايه
الموارد على الاراضي العامه في الاسكا
تتضمن اتخاذ خطوات للحد من انبعاثات
الكربون كما جادلت مجموعات بيئيه وقسم من
سكان الاسكا الاصليين بان المشروع سيضر
باهداف الرئيس المناخيه طموحه اضافه
لتشكيله اخطارا صحيه وبيئيه
ايضا بدا عشرات الالاف بتوجيه رسائل
مكتوبه وعرائد الكترونيه للبيت الابيض
للمطالبه بعدم الموافقه على المشروع اما
نائب الرئيس الامريكي الاسبق الجور فاعتبر
ان قرار الاداره سيعد متهورا وغير مسؤوله
واعتبر الجار ان مشروعه ويلو سيكون بمثابه
قنبله بيئيه بالنسبه لالسكا